this is the dean the danger
go down take the books put the books in
front of you and read them read the
Quran don't be afraid
the question is about whether Muslims
are or not good citizens the
Constitution defines what a good citizen
is and the Preamble it says we the
people of the United States in order to
perform a more perfect union to
establish justice ensure domestic
tranquility too many Muslim that can say
that is a good Muslim and most Muslims
can say that Muslims will Embrace that
most Muslims are good Americans
Obama you can take my daughter to dinner
you and my daughter and me
let me tell you something it's not it's
natural that's the idea God created it
and he created us to have a good time we
should have a good time only with our
wives though
Islam is the fastest growing religion in
the world and most of the converts are
women not men they see that the rules of
Islam instead of constraining them the
rules set them free
but you're gonna get old and things are
going to happen to you in your life and
then what have you got at the end of the
day it's an empty dream that has no real
Foundation we are gonna die and we're
gonna meet our Lord and he is going to
judge us it becomes an obligation for
each single human being to find out what
the Quran is Islam is telling us to stay
away from things which are bad for your
person and bad for the society
foreign
the Quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't kill old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the prophet Muhammad told us
that the prophet saws never ever start a
war against anyone
foreign
I figured I might as well worship the
Creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the religions
I remember finding out the meaning of
what Islam is what a Muslim is those who
surrender themselves to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will that is it Islam was pure it was
just you just pray to God you create
on the outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
you know Paradise right here on Earth
to go into someone's heart and change
their heart your job is to tell people
what the truth is and the reality of it
is while we're sitting here while I'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease
The Cure was free
with good deeds we'll find that good
breeds are good
clear out your mind and your heart of
hatred
okay and preconceived notions of racism
and nationalism because you cannot have
anything inside of you that's like that
against people and still be successful
this is the danger
of love there's only one God and Jesus
was his messenger alone
I don't know why I did that maybe maybe
it's just to break the ice